well it's 10 movie production trucks in
one a Las Vegas man who works in
Hollywood has combined almost everything
you need to shoot a film in one place
hitting the road as Nevada makes strides
and bringing more Hollywood productions
here to town eight news now reporter
Ryan Matthey shows us The Glitz and
glamor and potential use for this
sentence
I take all this and it all fits in there
all of it fits and we still have room
Carl Nicholas new company is saying
action think of it like an aircraft
carrier for the film business
nicholi has spent the last 15 years
producing movies TV shows and
commercials you have little trap doors
everywhere now combining most everything
he would need for a project into 153
foot long semi-tractor trailer lighting
cameras gripping on the bottom we're
going up we're going way up with enough
room to fit two prop cars on top just a
wall away from hair and makeup it's
basically anything outside of of a sound
stage and that's more and more being
relied upon as there's not enough sound
stages available it's very expensive to
shoot a multi-million dollar project
that could see more use in the near
future as Nevada makes strides of
bringing Hollywood Productions to Las
Vegas we want to have multiple films
here we want to have multiple TV shows
the Democratic state senator Roberto
Lang is looking to incentivize movie
studios to move in it's through SB 496
establishing a tax credit and
infrastructure program that also gets
around existing law if passed it would
mean 190 million dollars in tax breaks
each year which currently has a cap Sony
Studios already indicating it would
spend up to a billion dollars in
production if passed over a decade what
Nevada will reap from this will be far
and above what we're asking for in this
bill in tax credit and with this truck
Las Vegas could be ready for the
spotlight efficiency is the name of the
game you're paying by the minute when it
comes to film